[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates the
College Admission scandal the parents
charged today chose to corrupt and
illegally manipulate the system for
their benefit
celebrity actors corporate bosses
wealthy lawyers all caught in an FBI
sting accused of using bribes to get
their children into elite schools they
did not merit on their own I care about
school as a close look at the system
that drives wealthy parents to desperate
means in other words rich people are
insane
once you have that much money it poisons
your brain Plus too fancy to fly any
plane currently in the air will go to
its destination and thereafter be
grounded until further notice brand-new
737 airliners banned worldwide after two
fatal crashes strikingly similar now the
question of how US regulators first
okayed the new planes and then were
among the last to ground them and our
shoutout for the intrepid reporter for
The Weather Channel who faced hostility
from both the drug cartels and US
officials to discover what's really
behind the thousands of people trying to
make their way to the US border props
are failing people are going hungry and
they're coming because they don't have
anything to eat from the law and crime
Network students in New York City this
is Brian Ross investigates good evening
and welcome this is a month that
hundreds of thousands of high school
seniors around the country will be
waiting to learn where they may be going
to college next fall it is an agonizing
time making the news of a massive
cheating scandal involving college
admissions all the more disgusting 25
million dollars in bribes some eight
hundred students and some of the
country's best-known colleges the FBI
called it operation varsity blues
leading to the arrests of college
coaches test Proctor's and some thirty
three well-off parents the parents
charged today despite already being able
to give their children every legitimate
advantage in the college admissions game
instead chose to corrupt and illegally
manipulate the system
for their benefit among those charged
actor Felicity Huffman and Lori Loughlin
whose two daughters prosecutors say
gained admission to USC
thanks to five hundred thousand dollars
in bribes paid to the rowing team coach
her youngest daughter Olivia Jade told
her followers on this YouTube video how
little she cared about going to college
I don't know how much of school I'm
gonna attend but I do want the
experience of like game days partying I
don't really care about school as you
guys all know the FBI says some of the
parents helped arrange bogus photos of
their children to make it appear they
were athletes so that bribes college
coaches could use their slots to get
them admitted in one example the head
women's soccer coach at Yale in exchange
for $400,000 accepted an applicant as a
recruit for the Yale women's team
despite knowing that the applicant did
not even play competitive soccer the
mastermind
William singer has pleaded guilty in the
case and apparently worked with the FBI
after he was caught to record damaging
phone calls with many of the prominent
parents in other words rich people are
insane once you have that much money it
poisons your brain you either end up
bribing a soccer coach to get your kid
into Yale or if that doesn't work you
leave all your money to your cat joining
us now in the studio is Eric D makayley
director of admissions at reaches high
school in New York who has worked hard
to get hundreds of his students
including my son into some of the
country's top schools and joining us via
Skype from Boulder Colorado is Chris
hunt a journalist and writer who also
works as a college essay mentor to high
school students through the arduous
college admissions process and finally
joining us USC undergrads Morgan
stuffins and Frances Agustin who are
covering this story for the school paper
let me start with you two what do you
make of all this your school seems to be
at the center of it yeah it's it's a
crazy story but it's also a really good
lesson of journalism on the go
we're in Washington DC right now
actually on an academic program with the
Annenberg School and when the story
broke we got right to work
just finish the conversation waves of
congressmen and we immediately started
fact-checking scouring documents and I
think it just showed you know the real
world of how news can be and how once a
story breaks it's really time to get to
work and what do you make of the fact
that bribes we're able to get some
students apparently into USC I mean I
was I'll be honest I was rejected out of
high school and it's stunk for a while
but I'm obviously not there anymore
because they go here but I always think
to myself if I had those that's for two
years before I transferred here to seize
on opportunities that you se would have
provided me how much farther I could go
in my career and it makes me think that
I okay I felt cheated and a lot of these
students would cheated - Eric Tina
Kaylee here in New York what do you make
of the scandal these students talked
about how they felt cheated by it well I
I think it's just a logical extension of
the whole approach to college admissions
as a prize to be won and they're gonna
be people who are going to you know not
abide by the rules I think the more
criminal aspect is what's actually legal
in college admissions to be honest and I
think that there's a high level of
cynicism about the process to start with
and this will only exacerbate that level
had you heard anything about this
rumblings that there were people out
there who would do these kinds of things
college coaches you know again I
principally a teacher and an admissions
director for folks coming into readers I
would defer to my colleagues in the
College of missions process I read just
particularly our terrific director he's
son hang on on that yeah we live in New
York City so I'm sure that it's pretty
prevalent in terms of that not so much
at a place like Regis obviously but I
think it distorts the whole approach to
education when someone's sitting in
front of you and you're trying to
prepare them for the next stage in their
life there should focus should be on the
inventory of their present skills and
their development and thinking logically
about what's the next best stage for
them to develop those skills and that
should be the focus it's not like their
life is going to be immediately
guaranteed if they get into one college
or another
it'sit's the hard work of development is
still gonna have to take place in either
instance it seems these parents was so
intent on getting their children into
certain school as Chris Hutton vaulter
what drives that desperation by these
parents do you think well these
particular parents were probably driven
by the fact that they felt they didn't
have access through the legal but
questionable means that most people use
so a lot of people have power and money
that they put to use in other ways such
as going to a nice private school hiring
someone like me it is an advantage so
when you've run through that process and
you still don't have a lot of nice
status athlete status even at the other
end of the spectrum first in your family
to go to college if someone tempts you
with a back door and apparently that's
exactly what this guy did he would hold
this in front of you as an alternative
then some people will be tempted he
called it a back door our side door the
back door he said was when you give
money to the school up front the front
door when you get in under your own
auspices there is a side door I guess he
he created the side door so something I
think is a distinction worth making is
that the regular admissions process is
not being accused here no one bribed an
admissions officer because that person
has too many layers and too much
scrutiny around them no admissions
officer has the power to say yes but
they went through this athletic process
because the coaches once they say yes
basically have the power to get the
person in the admissions office to let
them in so this person was who committed
the crime was very good at probing for
the weak point and then finding people
who would agree to his terms he's got a
question from the control room they
helped me Rhonda mullet Rhonda Schwartz
our executive producer what's your
question Erin good question for you the
students who
parents are now charged with this what
about the students should they be thrown
out of school should they be held
responsible I'm not thinking so much
about their fate as I am about the
youngsters who were displaced in this
admissions process so if they're going
to stay and it's very difficult
particularly if they were unaware of
what their parents were doing I think
each of these schools should you know
compensate by adding a few more slots
for kids who might have been displaced
and - and also reevaluate their their
overall admissions process you know
again what's legal is even more
problematic than what's illegal this is
kind of obviously a moral failing but
you know certainly legacy preference
sports preference and the like that's
the thing that kind of limits the number
of slots that are open on a competitive
and meritocratic basis Morgan and
Francis how would you answer that
question what should happen to your
classmates whose parents apparently paid
bribes to get them into USC people who
are involved who are already at USC
they're already on their way to getting
their diploma so I don't think there's
any way that that the school can rectify
that on that end but they're gonna have
to focus more on the new incoming
students which i think is gonna just
make admissions a lot more challenging
in the future yeah I think that even if
the students did stay that you know
there might be a little bit of backlash
between the students that you know got
into merit and feel like they don't
deserve to be there quickly mr. Dean
Michaela will this lead to any reforms
you think this scandal I think it will
to the degree that it highlights the act
the regular process now and who squeezed
out in that particular process it also
makes poor folks and working-class folks
and first-generation folks very cynical
about it you know if there's some doubt
as whether they deserve to be there and
I'm fully committed to affirmative
action this certainly demonstrates is
it's pretty much a rigged game and I
would hate for anyone to sort of
disengage from that process because of
the you know sort of the cynicism that's
engendered by this process
Eric D makayley Chris hunt and voltar
and Morgan and Francis in Washington
thank you all for joining us tonight
coming up to fancy the fly troubling
news about the brand-new 737 now to some
disturbing news about airline travel
with the grounding of the entire fleet
worldwide of a brand-new
state-of-the-art jetliner raising the
question by some of whether it's too
fancy to fly it's called the 737 max
launched with great fanfare by Boeing on
its first flight three years ago despite
the wet weather the 737 max began its
first flight as smoothly as expected
[Applause]
but now in the wake of a second deadly
crash of the 737 max the entire fleet
worldwide has been grounded the US whose
FAA inspectors had approved the plans
for the 737 was among the last countries
to order the planes grounded at issue is
a key modification in the plane's flight
system that led the president to say
airplanes are becoming far too complex
to fly a statement widely mocked by the
late-night comedians here's President
Trump on the tarmac preparing for his
trip abroad he's declared air travel as
too complicated which is why it will be
flying in the newly designed Air Force
one
of course what has happened is no
laughing matter and to gain more insight
tonight we're joined by Christina
Groening author of the book the crash
detectives who's been reporting of the
737 developments this week for the New
York Times
mr. brownie thank you for being here how
long do you imagine this entire fleet
could be grounded well that is really
the million-dollar that is the
multi-million dollar question when you
think about all of the losses from the
airlines and Boeing and everyone else
the insurance companies but I'm gonna
say it's not gonna be a short grounding
I just don't think it's gonna be easy to
not only fix the software which I
understand Boeing is well involved in
getting a modification to the south
we're done but in actually testing out
that software and making sure that in
changing to fix one problem they don't
re-entrant or introduce problems that
they are unaware of so it's the testing
to make sure that this fix fixes without
harming somewhere else that I think is
gonna take some time I'm it's anybody's
guess and I don't want to weigh in I'm
more likely to be wrong than right but I
don't think it's gonna be short and the
core here is a device or software that
was designed to be actually a safety
feature isn't that right yes because
when they when the max was designed it
was actually they changed the engines
for a more
powerful engines and it changed the way
the airplane moves through the air
change the aerodynamics a bit and the
problem with that was it may attended to
make the airplane it made it slightly
more likely to stall and so they put
this anti stall protection software on
board the airplane there were two
problems with that it they did not
realize at the time that if there was a
faulty angle of attack indicator that it
might actually force the airplane into a
desert into a dive when it was not
required and second and probably the
larger problem that pilots were not
notified of this change and so that
pilots who were not deeply trained in
the 737 might be unaware that to take
the power off the the trim the the trim
control they might actually fix it and
so the pilots in the Lion Air case we
believe it's all very initial that they
were struggling with the airplane
without doing what they should have done
to get the power you know to get the
power off the the tail the flight
control surfaces on the tail so you know
it's a matter of training it's a matter
of you know unexpected problems on the
on the airplane pilots trusting a
brand-new airplane over their own
piloting skills you can certainly
understand that so there's a lot of
components like every aircraft air air
accent and there's a lot of factors that
go into it and yet mr. brownie this was
a system approved by the FAA and the FAA
with among the last countries if not the
last agency to sort of ground these
airplanes what's going on here are they
just too cozy with the airline industry
with Boeing I've heard that but I don't
really think that was a factor here I
made an effect I don't think it was the
primary factor look aviation relies on
data they want to see data before they
make a decision and there was not data
coming out of Ethiopia and that is a
problem I mean I put some of the
culpability on this delay in this crazy
crazy grounding here patchwork of
groundings I have put some of the
culpability there on Ethiopia for not
getting those black boxes somewhere
earlier they sat on them for two and a
half days was no reason for that
so that there is information available
we know because the Canadians already
told us that there was information
available from satellite data that came
off the airplane that showed more likely
than they originally thought that this
was related to the crash in Lyon air but
why did why was there two days before
the information came back to the
Canadians and to the and to the FAA so
while people are saying oh the FAA is
too cozy with Boeing I don't really
think it's that I think the FAA was
waiting for data meanwhile other
countries were listening to what
passengers were saying which is we're
worried and they responded to that and
that's a legitimate you know that's a
legitimate issue also you don't want the
traveling public to be frightened by
getting on an airplane
it's another component in the decision
making well Christie Negroni thank you
very much for being here tonight we look
forward to your future reporting in The
New York Times
coming up our shoutout for the reporter
who braved hostility on both sides of
the border to get an important story
our shout out tonight for a brave reaper
who has had to find ways to work around
two powerful groups that don't want him
to tell the story of what's happening
along the US border
the brutal Mexican drug cartels on one
side and antagonistic US officials on
the other my name is John Carlos Frey
and I am an independent investigative
reporter I would be probably naive to
say that it's not a dangerous place I
have been held at gunpoint several times
I have been threatened with my life on
several occasions I have been held
against my will for a few days but
listen I'm a reporter and I work in what
some people would call a warzone and
that's just part of the job last week it
was reported that the US government had
kept a list of reporters who were
targeted to be stopped if they came
across the border to my knowledge I
wasn't on the list the last time I tried
to get into the United States I was in
Central America and booked a flight back
to Los Angeles and I was held in customs
for five hours without any information
as to why I'm pretty sure that that all
of my luggage as well as my laptop was
gone through pretty meticulously so I'm
assuming that if I'm not on the list I'm
being watched
I'm catching up with a caravan once
they've already been on the road for a
month travelled almost a thousand miles
and are arriving in Mexico City Frey
essentially embedded with one of the so
called caravans as hundreds traveled
from Central America making their way to
the US border leading president Trump to
declare a national emergency we're
talking about an invasion of our country
with drugs with human traffickers with
all types of criminals and gangs but for
a special report that aired on the
weather channel Exodus the hunger that
consumes you Frei uncovered a surprising
much different angle
the story I find a lot of people who
worked on farms and say that they fled
because of the drought gita is pequeña
you know what I didn't toast aperitivo
pepper deer one of the major reasons
that people are coming up is because of
climate change of all things people are
hungry they are experiencing a drought
in Central America that's gone on for
now close to five years crops are
failing people are going hungry and
they're coming because they don't have
anything to eat that's something that
doesn't seem to be reported on that
people are knocking on the US door
because they're hungry croc in my own
low error on the Descent Amash como el
hombre que I think they try and see my
species of death and his Weather Channel
report with lead producer Sally
Granite's teen documented the accounts
of the families trying to get to the US
backed up with experts on meteorology
and famine a story largely untold in
other media outlets just last month the
United Nations declared that 2.1 million
people have reached a type of famine
status compared to four hundred thousand
people the year before I hooked up with
The Weather Channel who was interested
in reporting this from a climate
perspective but the fact that millions
of people may be suffering from famine
in the next year - I don't see a lot of
reporting which for Frey and his team is
reason enough to brave the dangers in
Mexico and the official hostility on the
US side to stay on the story finding a
way to get his reporting out even
without the big budgets and resources
of the mainstream media so we don't have
a satellite truck and we don't have a
lot of complicated ways of broadcast so
we just do a Facebook live report and
that's how we've been getting that
information out which seems to be
received pretty well the stories are
still there so I have a job to do so our
shuttle tonight - john-carlos fry a
reporter who continues to go or a few
others do that's our program tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you back here next week